Oh wait, how do you fit me in life?
I don't know what to pop it, ah good morning, I see it, it says I'm up, I'm sorry I'm up,
good morning, good evening, good afternoon, we've learned, hiya, America, hiya, hiya,
I literally just woke up right, and then I quickly scrolled Twitter whilst I've got like
literally one thirty seconds to my name after like booting up the stream and everything
and Emmys like, wait actually you know what, I can freaking quote it and I can let you listen to
hold on let's find, oh my god I don't have any DMs with Emmys on Twitter, oh my god proof that there's
inciting at me allure, right are you ready for this, her most recent tweet that I just saw,
wow I'm so happy I'm not three hours into a shift at the cash register dealing with old people
complaining that the newspaper got ten cent more expensive, I love my job, also Emmys
get pregnant, get pregnant, get pregnant, get pregnant, get fucking pregnant you precious little slut, get pregnant
yeah, damn straight you love your job either one, we're playing Wata Melan
and I love the Wata Melan meme, no the meme is not overused is I had email notifications on and just got here
I hide them for hours playing Suika or Suika or Suikobliat
so yeah, I have email notifications on I'm still late, why would you have email notifications on, that's so curse
but I feel okay today please don't worry, I looked at Marshmallow, I'm so sorry for worrying anyone
I did not, I've never played this game before, no
I am so sorry for stressing anyone out, I'm gonna quickly read the super chats I missed yesterday
Sada, thank you for the extended membership and their message was face
like the capital D face
Veeler Lover, how the hell can she be a tease when she's still out of breath
because on my dying breath I will be a tease
Nero2276, thank you for the super chat, is this the bite of Vsucky?
is this the bite of 87?
good reference, anonymous
I've once heard that females can have miniature inking from work out, this is true
Stony's panting sounds like she's recording an audio, no no no
it is true, women can experience a floor firework if you will, a floor muscle firework
thank you for that tip anonymous and then anonymous said good job mami
good job Riflin, you did amazing, now give us
now give us you a nice little, oh massage all over your body, I'll take it honestly
I'm ironically a bit small, small, so are
but today we are testing if in fact it's true or not
if this game truly has VTubers in a chokehold
jesus, that's blind and first thing in the morning, can we change?
Aladdin, Prince of the Fabulous, he's drowning in water
I do not know the words
can we stop blinding myself, oh my god can you load faster
I thought this was like a tiny little indie game, honestly
are you squidding me right now?
thank you for the super chat really legend
so what I'm hearing is I have to look for a VOD, if you'd like to
okay first off cute adorable, Kawaii-nee
mm-hmm, mm-hmm, okay
single player plays, well that's the only option I've got
apparently the DLC's behind the paywall
are you squidding me right now?
still didn't even have the fill thing, I'm not kidding
I've got a cup of tea to wake me up
oh my god reeflings
reeflings, I have something that I need to keep for you guys
only you guys are allowed to know this
don't leak it anywhere or I can't keep leaking stuff
I found artwork of someone that like drew
that draws feet, right?
okay
and I commissioned them to draw everyone's feet in the allure
okay and I was so fucking excited to get that
turned down the game I think a bit
anonymous, thank you for the tip
hi story, I can't believe you and Emmy are going back and forth with our no-
no, no, no, no, Emmy's first
I bet it would be fun to see pinpals versus re-
no, no, no, no, no, no, no
that's not how, personally that's not how I do it
I actually want the girls to be ahead of me
I've kind of said this before
I've put advertisement money behind the girls
but I've not done it myself
the only exception was the trailer
because all of us for debut had to generate some kind of hype
and unfortunately Shibi and Azura's big fat yunkers
stopped their ads from running on their trailer
which is quite upsetting
but I personally do not do it like that
I am not here to outdo my genmys
I actually want them all to succeed
and be ahead of me
so when Emmy went ahead
I was absolutely ecstatic
I truly was ecstatic
and she's still ahead
which I'm very happy about Shibi
I've given an ASMR script too
which she will be recording
soon to end
when she's not at her grand-pappy
parents house
I think that's where she is
boobs
I'm trying to draw, I saw you draw Emmy too
I'm okay
is your sweat toggle still on?
it is!
thank you Reefling
I couldn't see that
oh my god I'm such a professional streamer
I also managed to get my order changed
before it came through
so the dog bowl and the dog collar
are gonna say the right things
I don't know how you noticed that
from so far away
I would have played the entire game sweating
literally
I hope you liked my silly drawing
are you joking? I'm yonking at making ASMR
right, how to play Suika
use the
yes
or up and down to move
no we're not doing up and down that's terrible
we'll use the less stick
next press the A button to drop the fruit
uhhhh
okay I guess
I didn't read the rest of the thing
right
okay
hold on
I'm just getting used to the mechanics
if you will
okay
hold on let me get up let me get up
let me go up
so this is what had VTubers
in a choke hold for how long
this
am I addicted yet
the answer sadly is no
I'm not I'm not sure if I'm gonna get addicted
I'm unsure
I have yet to form an opinion on such a game
what's going on here it still has a
choke hold on VTubers does it actually
well I see
someone very
I think someone might have
gone on her throne and got her switch
I said to her
oh I'm playing this game
and I'll recommend it to you
ooh we got a lemon
I'll recommend it to you if you're
wanting
recommendations because I'm trying to help her pick a few games
that are more her style
oh fuck that one up
oops
so I need what pray that
they're just gonna randomly touch each other
okay I guess
oh no I can't reach the orange one
over the mandarin
oh god I think I'm like
really I think I'm screwing this up
sorry wait hold on a minute
I'm messing this up so badly
oopsies I still loving
what kind of games do I see
I see needs a casual experience
and no I don't mean that and then
so do you
relax
I just mean that I see likes a game
I don't have to swear on
okay or is a familiar game so I'm putting the list together
I didn't mean competing against
oh sorry anonymous I apologize
I did not mean to paint your
tip in that light my apologies that was my fault
I just think it would be fun
to make a challenge of viewer fans
just like Emmy did were pin pals so everyone can
get ahead of you
did she tell you the challenge she did
yes there's actually
this is inside her knowledge
fucking strongy stop leaking inside
your knowledge challenge impossible
I am going to do a meet and
oh I got you a pink thing
what's a pink fruit
that's that big a melon
maybe there's a pink melon
but it's not the water melon
um
I'm literally impossible
for me not to leak in company secrets
it's just a big peach oh it's a peach
it's my booty
fuck you booty fuck you bitch
um sorry that was
I think that's a meme of some kind
um
I am not strategically playing this game
I actually don't know what I'm doing
I'm just having a good time okay
no touch yay
oh you can touch
touch touch yes yes
oh my god okay hold on a minute
hold on a minute hold on a minute
I think I'm starting to understand
again VTubers I might
have to issue a public apology
I might have to
issue on a public apology hold on
a minute
I might have to do it
um right okay company secrets
getting leaked in 4k
I'm having a meeting with the girls
and I'm telling them like hey this method
seemed to really work for me so if you
want to offer free audios
on Twitter in exchange for like
milestones I'm happy with that
like I have so much ASMR
debt and audio debt
on Twitter coming up but once
it's finished like I might
do something like that and be like
oh for I don't even know how many
for 15k subscribers I'll do this
outrageous thing okay see now I'm
starting to block myself
I'm not really
sure what to do
I mean I'll just go for it I mean
it's alright it's just a fun little
goofy game it's actually
oh no oh no this can't be right
go move over please
no
yes oh well I didn't
expect that one to move actually
oh we got the pitch
oh
head empty drop that motherfucking
boot
apology arc inbound already I prefer
the company leaks in the form of puzzles
okay I'll keep that in mind
okay I'm gonna say something
there may or there may not be
a very high quality artwork
I purchased for the 10th
10,000 subscriber milestone
so once all the girls hit 10,000
subscribers there may or may not
be an adorable artwork of us all
if I've not already leaked it I probably
have already
I prefer company leaks
in terms of the juices
I mean
you know I'm here
I leak literally everything about the
I can't help it I get so excited
but I'm so upset because we actually
have
something
am I gonna block myself? I think I am a
little bit
we actually have something I'm not allowed to leak
right now and all I'm gonna say is it is torture
sorry but I'm not even being dramatic
when I say that it is torture
oh it's so cute
what's like the average score
I wonder if I should like oopsies
I mean maybe it's better it got pushed
over
stop leaking
damn fine can't help it
yeah we have to get everyone to 10k
happy pineapple literally
what's that pineapple been so cute for
the average is 1,800
are you wearing clothes in the artwork
uh
no really not really
no not in the artwork
no average score is 2k
I don't know your main goal at least
at least get one watermelon
literally it's the best meme I don't know
why people are sick of it I don't care I get spammed
everywhere I love watermelon
okay let me finish my cup of tea
whilst I leak company
secrets as I always do
the clipping program
has been green lit for $2
per 1000 views
there is a cap
at 100k
so the maximum money you could make
from a clip is $200
however if that clip
for some reason like blew the fuck up
I need to rate it out
in a specific way where it's like you get more
money if it blows up but it has to reach a
milestone so like 250k
and then you'd get a payout for that
and clips are like obviously clips
need to have a timer on them
however we do have exceptions for
algorithm clips so clips that get
picked up in the algorithm mean
they weren't picked up at the start but maybe
3 months down the line it randomly got
we have an exception for that
so I am in the
process of
hold on I can play one handed
and drink tea and leak company secrets
I love this game
oh I missed
oh no
can I like force it to touch that one
I can wait this is
actually physics simulator hold on
something's going on over there
I'll pop you there
a strongy snail
veal or snowden honestly
can't hold me back
youtube is currently cracking down on clip channels
yes that's why we wanted
to offer
money and exchange
and now you have to get except
oh no
I need those cherries to kiss
draft hmm
I don't think I can get the cherries to kiss
unless I can I push the yellow
thing away
ooh
why am I like
this
they're moving everything's moving
okay
hold on a minute
yes I got approval for that so I need to
write it yesterday I was writing the
script
it's currently my longest script
oh god I've messed this up
how are you supposed to like
can you plan ahead mentally
maybe you can
maybe you can plan ahead mentally
what if I do this
nothing's touching right I'm being
a bit silly like spreading everything out like this
if only
they could touch
well that bought me some time
right if those two pink ones
can just touch each other
are you squidding me right now
stuff's happening
I'm not even paying attention thank you
Gavabond for becoming an extended membership
update on Mercy and Azura's emotes
Azura's getting too fixes
Mercy's getting too fixes and then they will be up
and then I will order the
order the missing emotes
for everyone those little love hearts
you see these are place holders
for the emotes that the girls can unlock
thank you to any support that is shown
via membership to the girls
whether it is gifted or purchased by yourself
it is
are you squidding me right now
I forgot I had this happy moment
thank you Rekima for this
oh shit why not
oh stuff's poppin
stuff's poppin
are you okay though
there's like such a big gap down there
oh come on
go a little to the right
no go to the right
no no I need to push it to the right
come on go to the right
oh wait why aren't you touching
are you being so for real right now
you better touch right now
I'm sorry for being great
DEMPA you have a wrench
you don't can
you've seen the meme rebecca's take away shop
edgin and my sakeer game
more likely than you think
she's approaching the end of her run
oh I'm messing it up
I mean it doesn't look that bad
if I could get the pink ones to touch
I don't know
I mean for the first attempt
like you have to give it to me sorry
but this is a good first attempt
I think it's a good first attempt anyway
so what do I need
you put my little strawberries together
put these together
oh no I messed
up then you look
then you look I'm embarrassed
okay there we go
can the cherries touch? why is nothing wanting to touch each other
are you allergic to each other
do you have a fruit allergy
can I like drop it to push it over
come on
split them apart
it's come on physics similar
I saw this game's actually not that bad
I'm sorry vTubers
I don't know why I doubt you guys
literally I want to play supermarket simulator so
badly
but no one's gonna enjoy it
and I'm like
doesn't Suica
have a button that bounces them
stop
it says move A for drop
X for menu
Y for ranking
switch ranking
I don't have that
I don't even have the melons yet
I mean
no I've only had a pineapple
but my score is over a thousand
so for my first attempt
I'm
oh
that's not good
that's not good at all
oh no
I didn't look at the life cycle
of the fruit properly
oh no wait
why did I do that
can things start
touching please
can things start shoving
each other out of the way
oh no it's ogre
what did I get
that's so good
okay let me write that down
hold on write that down
that's not that bad
I'm not even mad so I was
right high score
it's okay groups you
what was the context
it keeps track for you
oh did I not even need to pin it
oh okay
monthly daily overall
right you have entered
the ranking
okay
did I just restart
right we got
we got a pineapple on our first attempt
I don't know where I went horribly wrong
I mean
no
why are you going all the way over there
stop being so dramatic honestly
don't roll away
do I make myself clear
don't you dare roll away
I literally went halfway
across the map
vealer's suica arc
I think emmy has a switch as well
so
she wants a cam stream
like so whenever I finish a game
always taping like a little review
in the discord and I'm like hey guys
this was a two over experience
this is what happened in the game
it was just a fun and a goof and a gaffe
basically and I'm like I'm sure
they're probably sick of it they're like
oh we get it strongy
shut off about your damn game
but like always review them and I'm like
oh if you want a chill game experience
I was picking my schedule
for when my dad goes home
and to avoid all the depression
and I picked lego lord of the rings
to cheer me up
so don't be surprised
when you see lego
rollie pollie's away literally
strongy vs emmy suica
addition yes suica
or suica
yes I'm literally between lego lord
of the ring I'm so excited
we will eventually see
strongy in a steam
game review
I wanted to do an indie game review
series where we give like
indies a shot because like
sometimes all you need is
like you know what
you know what an example is among us is an example
of like someone
picking up a game if you didn't know
among us came out and it wasn't
even that popular like at all
and
I don't know if that's a terrible idea
oh I've done it now
I've done it now that was a
terrible idea don't ever do that again
I'm sorry are you squidding me right now
touch
touch touch
more people need to
write reviews on streams from the
perspective of a streamer the
veiler game jam when
real or
steamer game
be sucky to be
sweet
is lego lord of the rings the same level of quality
as old star wars yes
I literally
this sounds really sad but I remember
where all the items are hidden and everything
and the maps are so what we're going to do
when we play lego lord of the rings is
I'm going to play through the entire campaign
and then we're going to go back and pick up
all the stuff because I know where everything is
why am I throwing am I throwing
why did that work out the game
just let me throw
oh my god I love when the game lets you throw
and it like bails you out randomly
pansley gameplay oh yeah
pansley's go up
august 1st the girls get access
actually on the last day
of this month
and it's up to them how much they want to do
and they keep 100% of their cut
because veiler did not specify they had to stream
on that website so we don't take anything
so if you want to support them you may support
away have you tried
shadow of mordor
I thought I did I looked at gameplay
I think I must have played a demo or something
so we're actually going to play that
for the first time yeah we got pizza already
we're going to play
it's technically for the first time but I am
familiar with the mechanics I mean we'll find out
on the day when I play honestly right let me finish
this team before it gets freaking freezing cold
well anyone be posting links
the names are already taken exactly
as found so you don't really need to dig
you'll see them and use their alternative
twers anonymous thank you for the tip
I was rewatching
the yumi plus concert reaction and the thought
came to my head I can imagine
scrawny going on a hype rock rampage
singing
songs by my chemical romance
she be caught in bumps sounds like she would
enjoy singing R&B
we were we're going to talk
about it in the meeting
I don't think it would be cute
but I did not know this
emi has insane
stage fright when it comes to singing
I didn't know
I thought she was joking
em because she like put a little
cute message because we have dm's
with yumi plus like all the girls in yumi plus
they're all sorry let me finish my tea holy crap
I can't keep rambling it's going to go freezing
what do you think of bandsley versus patreon
patreon is a staple
income source whereas bandsley is not for the girls
so I obviously
I'm biased if you want to support the girls
doing it via patreon
I've got an azeria update actually
I need permission to talk about it
if she's still with it or not hold on
are you cool with me
talking about
I actually have a collab
with azeria today so I hope you're not sick of her
because I get to play with her today
okay
I don't know a good place to put these down
I don't even did I do that
I feel like the game did that for me
I feel like the game has like a tiny little
magnet that gives you a
who goes there a few pixels of like relief
because that's insane
what's going on here
I've got
apparently azeria shorts
are about to come through tomorrow and I'm freaking
humping this screen
because azeria has like hilarious shorts
coming through
emmy oh my god right sorry
I keep mentioning emmy
she like she'll send me shorts
and it's literally emmy and denpa talking
about cheese
and I'm like emmy what do you want me to do
with this clip how am I supposed to turn it
into something that's appropriate
and she's
she's just fucking she's amazing
she's a hoot in a hauler to work with
I don't care what anyone says sorry but
literally my little sister is so
freaking adorable
I don't care
literally so in the discord
this is just straight up leaks at this point
in the discord there's a channel where the girls can submit clips
so if you guys clip anyone's stream at any point
and you give it a title
she'll be able to she'll send it to me
and then I'll send it on to Nedder
as I said she's got a song cover coming out soon
I'm just waiting for a few things to finalize
and then it'll come out
although I think it might be delayed unfortunately
it was supposed to come out when she was away on holiday
but oh my god sorry let me finish this tea
I've still not finished it
it's gonna be frozen
that's straight tea
that was a rubbish tea
cute daughter emmer's honestly
nah I love all the girls
they're actually like so fun to work with
I don't care what I like literally they're just
ooh right
so this is the problem
the pineapple is now taking up the middle section
I'm needing it to take a laugh
thank you vealer lover for the tip
why did you split it up like that
viotin
why does that look suspicious
am I gonna get
emmy can do no wrong
I might be biased he says with her oh she marks in his name
what cloud met me
audo
cloud me audo
what is it
oh dear god
wait I was joking
I was gonna pretend that it was a bad game
the first thing
that comes up on youtube
cloud me audo
sexy monster
you're done viotin
you're done
we are playing this wholesome
humble game
and what do you want to do
you want to
the sanctity
okay we've got orange
ooh
oh my god actually I'm going to get sephrenic
I was listening to azure's stream yesterday
whilst I was writing the pregnancy script ASMR
I could have sworn at one point
she sounded like freaking iron mouse
she made a voice and it sounded just like her
and I was like
I didn't know you could make that voice
monster supremacy
my eyes hurt now
yeah it's just straight up
right okay we'll play on fans later
I'm not to say the word out of the loop sorry
viotin thank you for the two part chat
and veil are loved too
and anon and kaidon and everyone
ruining the say so
the stream oh my
oh me oh my
shock and horror when my
freaking run in stream got limited ads
oh I'm so
oh no I didn't want it to go over there
oh my god touch
touch if you love each other
come on it's moving
it's moving you know
the one I'm looking at right it's rotating
a little bit
MGQ whatever this game is
what do you mean you aren't
in absolutely thrilled
to watch this watermelon simulator
sorry is this not got you on the edge of your
seat have you not got
adrenaline pumping
through your veins at the
thought of how just
gorgeous in enticing
this gameplay is I mean doesn't this
not make you want to
do something
I don't know what it would want to
come on look at this watch this
oh wait
oh we've got a watermelon
oh wait no we've not this isn't a war
that's not the big watermelon
okay we're making progress
ladies and gentlemen
it makes me want to play more of the
game I mean something's
pumping through me now that's a honey
oh it's a cantaloupe
okay honey dude cantaloupe got it got it
okay surely
and don't call me surely
surely
we can
we can do this
okay
I don't think this is gonna
touch I think the
honey dude is gonna be in the way
one more of those
and then we get the watermelon
not me already completing the
game in my second try
okay maybe I'm getting a bit too cocky hold on
literally Han Solo don't get
too cocky kids if I drop
this I think it's gonna get blocked so I'm not
gonna put it there on oh wait
no should I put it there
as a platform to work with
okay I'm gonna put it there as a platform to work
with I will learn the hard way if that
wasn't the correct move
I'm just gonna like mix them
all in a wee bowl down here
oh
mmm okay see that's
wacky ah okay
okay it's not looking good bruv bruv
bruv it's not looking good I'm gonna shove you there
and then I'm gonna put you there
and then you're gonna kiss
kiss right now kiss right now
kiss if you want to stop
global
famine perfect thank you
the orange is moving
oh no that cherry is gonna be all alone
I'm not alone
there's no one
I am not expecting the honey
juice to go up
but it is
we got the melon between the water
this has got the same
tension as bobble bubble
oh is that another game
you don't run into many surely
surely not
you've got a decent set up
not too many fruit trapped underneath
oh I'm not to trap them underneath
trap them underneath
mmm the bigger the fruit
are surprisingly
late in the physics
I'm learning
I'm learning right pop
that was not what I wanted it to be
why are you going down
it keeps pushing the honey do
up but I'm not really wanting it
to be up
not really wanting it to be up
if I'm being honest
it's kind of ruining the flow
of my gameplay
actually I'm ruining the flow
of my gameplay I'm currently
sabotaging myself what is this
okay okay and it
kiss
right now
I can't believe it I'm shipping fruit
I'm gonna have to shove this over here
oh things are moving
wait no things are rotating
oh okay
I think I've bolstered up
oh unless
have I bolstered up
a little bit
feels like an invaded
balloon indeed
it pops upwards oh my god
I can't believe this Nintendo game cater to
inflation fit sorry
I don't know why I said that stop
stop I'm literally trolling
and it's like first thing in the morning
but yes I'm playing I'm coming online
for a second stream today because I'm playing with Azura
and we were here
oh and she's never played it
before so
okay
I'm at the edge of my seat oh yeah
yeah so Matt I'm so excited for
what happens next will the fruit pop
find out after the break
I don't really
do I want to put it there I'm not really sure but
oh god oh
I'm making this like so bad oh what's
going on okay
okay
okay oh
I beat my rank I beat my last score
high
score
right should I put that there
okay
if those two touch
they'll become an orange
okay wait hold on let's
do some
oh my god
actually kind of smart mildly smart
moves hold on
why are you try hard in the fruit game
I'm sorry but I play video games
to win that's why I literally
play legendary mode on Skyrim excuse
me like what's
the problem what's the problem
oh come on you skinny
legend go down
is that actually not
going to go down I don't think that's
going to go down melons
we can meet at right now for a while
hi evening thank you
for joining the water melon game
this is the first time I'm playing it
and I've unlocked the honeydew
but I ain't unlocked the other things
this cuttlefish works hard for
she plays hard damn straight at you
I'm literally going off after this
and then I'm going for a nap and then I'm
waking up and then I'm going to talk to
her for an hour just
yeah for head off
okay
this one isn't going to pop on its
own so I might as well add that
oh I've just done something
so silly
unless can I push it
out
come on
oh well okay
I've just killed myself
in the game
bye
during your heroes donathan suggestions
stream I asked her for a mama and
mommy NSFW audio as a reward
what would you think
that's not a problem
I'll be a lover
Azura planned her
rewards with you guys
and then I'm going to come in behind them
and pimp them out and then I will
seek her approval I didn't have time to do
it yesterday because I was writing my
pregnancy somewhere
oh my god my dad came up to my PC
so he doesn't normally like lurk over
my PC or anything and I was
legit typing like oh I can't wait to meet
you like I can't wait to like give birth
and feed you for the first time and all of that
I mean he came up to the fucking PC
and I had to like start playing with the desktop
and that I'm like no I'm not that I'm just doing
a wee bit of work like I was like oh my god
like please
so my dad doesn't give like two rats
ours but it's a lot harder
to explain like why I'm
fucking writing pregnancy ASMR
than it is to be like
you know I'm just writing like a script
right now like you probably don't want to
type thing oh I've just
ruined it unless
no it's not gonna pop
nothing's gonna pop
if things started rotating maybe
but it's
ogre I've ruined it
I've ruined it
I've ruined it no
okay sorry
but we did actually get a pretty decent score
I'm actually not too mad
unless
no wait you popped
and then no the game killed
itself don't be so rude
right one seven two three that was really good
hold on
high score
hold on I can't take it
one seven two six
right in my head
please
the way I actually
can't put
I believe in you you'll be able to play with melons
soon enough
I'm not done thank you Kaidon and thank you
Brian for reading it
the first round
shambles it's a learning moment
getting stronger right strawberry don't go halfway
across the map I'm putting you on the right
side because I know you're gonna try and roll
yeah that's right
that's right I've got you figured out little strawberry
don't think I don't know what you're doing
I know exactly what shenanigans
you're up to
or should I say
stop everything's rolling
rolling rolling rolling rolling
what rolling rolling rolling
come on
meow
meow meow meow
are you squinting me right now
who goes there identify yourself
what
I'm sure there's like a good tactic I haven't solved it yet
I mean
it's alright I would say the game
is fun when you're winning
but when the game looks like you're not really getting
anywhere it's just kind of like
ahh
I missed oh
you cheated you made it look like
you were gonna be a thing
you think you did
anonymous what do you say I gotta be funny
if all the reeflings wrote wholesome messages to pathastronic
so he doesn't have to worry his daughter's
fans aren't treating her right no he's
fine with you guys I think he's
actually gonna write a letter for you
so that I get to read but I'm only allowed to
read it when he's away I'll probably end up crying
impressive she stayed
relatively calm you having fun
it's amy it's alright
I don't know
maybe it's just kind of one of those games
because I just remember
it came out and
everywhere you looked
it did not matter who you looked at
they were sitting on this game challenging
each although that was actually probably the fun
of it challenging each other to like
oh if you get
cherries please touch
if you get like
X amount of
you know
addiction yes basically
and the lyrics limit biscuit
Lauren unironically rames the word here
with the word here literal
lyrical crime
yeah the competitiveness
I just remember everyone was like oh this is
my score beat it and then everyone was
like today we're going to be in the score
and I think that's where
the fun of it came in
I don't know maybe I'm allowed to set it
and then I'll challenge the girls because I know
emmy's got a switch
ac just got a switch
oh that was it oh my god sorry the minute though
it's a bit satisfying hold on a minute this game
hold on hold on I was a bit hasty in my review
that was rather satisfying
um
oh I just blocked myself off
and it doesn't matter because it just
bounced halfway across the map that's fine
I didn't want that anyway
um
oh okay we've got a peach
we've got a peach
ah
I just got the watermelon on my third attempt
stop you guys
someone said that they said they were playing a game
alongside me and they had
beat it like three times over by the time
I won my first attempt at it I can't remember
what game it was and I was like
are you literally sniping the game
and doing like ten times better than me
um I was absolutely
he hot and at the
concept you're just doing like way better and being like
right hurry up streamer come on
strongy we're waiting for the result
um
okay
we're gonna match you
watermelon for melon honestly
right I've got two peaches
I don't know how to make them kiss
see I don't know how to just
I keep doing that I keep going
oh there's enough room there's not enough room
strongy please please
there's not enough room
I don't know why something
oh I don't know sometimes it'll
move in the oh come on
no
say it ain't so
I will not go
turn the lights
oh they kiss
was it valid true it might have been
it might have been because I checked
my marshmallows after stream and you guys always
say such nice things I'm so sorry to worry
you guys again I had loads of marshmallows
that were like are you alive
I literally passed out after stream
I was so weak
in frail
I had this fruit juice in the fridge
so I opened that up and like
took a few sips and then passed out
and I think it was like low I hadn't
had anything to eat I'd just
woken up I didn't stretch I haven't
exercised in ages
um like all of those factors
came together at the same time
and it was like ooh shouldn't have done that
by the way
I had a really fun time on the stream though
like I enjoy Ring Fit I like
that it's different I like that I can move around
I think it would be a lot more
effective if it was a 3D stream
like a 3D model stream
things are gonna have to start
kissing or I'm gonna be in trouble
I think I'm in trouble things aren't kissing
okay but again same
problem things aren't kissing
unless we
force them to kiss
no I'm just
creating a gap and now I've created a problem
I've created a monster
nobody wants to see Marshall no more
he's top level
Ring Fit can never harm you again
well like everyone was like
oh my god your heart rate and I'm like
oh wait I've not told you the lore here
I haven't
like an abnormal heart rate it's faster
I'm a hamster
too long didn't read
I'm a hamster okay don't worry
about my heart rate it's normal for me
it's not normal for you but it's normal for me
I'm on how am I messing
this up so badly I'm on
like observations and if I ever
have any concerns about my heart I'm just
no what am I doing
what am I doing
right stop rambling
and start try hard and I'll make myself
clear
yes
oh my god I'm in so much trouble
no I think I've just thrown
no don't get in the way
little cherry
are you squiddin me right now
Stroney please be careful next time
there is no
for without you oh there is so
violour with every way
I promise you the girls would do
just fine they'd keep thriving
doing their thing I mean I've told them
all the behind the scenes stuff that
I'm doing for them so they know
how to like you know
I don't know why I sounded
like a monkey the first time there but okay
hold on we have second breath
we have second wind we have second wind
thank you violour lover I assure you the girls would do
just fine what are you doing you the best
I thought you were all
the girls though
dada obviously
I'm so sorry actually
my dad said hi to AC yesterday
I was like
dad say Privyat she's Russian
and he was like
he couldn't get it out and I'm just like
Privyat Privyat
but she couldn't hear him in the headset
and I was like oh not really
echoes of monkey noise
in the distance honestly
see I like when it does it
by itself
oh no
what is going on over there
oh my god kiss
I dare you to kiss little purple grapes
actually
I believe in red grapes
superiority over green grapes
I said what I said it's like red apples
red apples are sweet
green apples are sour
grandaddle
AC's true dada
no no that's my dad
no my dad
no stop it
stop it
you're harassing me and winning
oh something popped
I like when it randomly pops
I'm like ooh what was that
I have to go now be back later
thanks for hanging
I don't know if Emmy is up next
that's not gonna kiss
I'm throwing I'm throwing again
no kiss the other way
I'm being trolled
I just suck at this game
honestly
you know how about I just accept the fact I suck
how about that
instead of try hard and being upset
every time I do
I'll come on
no
please rotate
a little to the left
okay
something's moving
are you squidding me right now
okay
throwing for content
the fanbases would be upset
no all the girls are fine
what the
no I'm not gonna die
I promise literally the doctor
cleared me and she was like
if you have any concerns just come back in
because I was saying like I have loads of palpitations
and all that
and I have a faster resting heart rate
heart rate and she was like you're just a hamster
smell
okay
at least
I need you the other game but I've completely
balls it up
I don't know what the secret method or tactic is
but I have yet to figure it out
I'm not throwing for content I'm just dumb
okay those are two separate things
these are two issues we're having to deal with
at the same time I'm just
incredibly dumb okay
thank you
vealer lover
wait there's our club is tomorrow
but like today tomorrow not tomorrow
it's in three hours wait have I
is it not in three hours
we spoke about it
yesterday hold on hold on
I'm like pretty sure it's
in three hours well it's like
one hour earlier
are you screwed me right now
wait what are you
screwing me
yeah it's like
at 10 am so it's at 9 am
because she said we could do it an hour early
yeah it's in three hours
I dare you
god that was a shit score don't look at that
I'm embarrassed that was worse than my first
attempt at this game
don't clap don't clap
game you're embarrassing me anonymous I can't believe
my oh she's like me I have the same condition
we both have a hamster heart
refling huh
the lady has three hearts she's throwing
five ish hours maybe four yeah
three hours is tomorrow for some of us
how dare you be in a different time zone
no don't clap it was a terrible attempt
are you trying to embarrass me
oh my god they go flying
please kiss
okay I'm happy with that
they kissed
nah stop I look over and it's just a sea of clapping
literally why is the game
clapping oh you did rubbish attempt
oh oh rubbish oh
just to really yeah oh you suck
come on
who's getting 46k
46k
who is getting 46k
are you joking
who is that
is that someone in whole life be honest
right now sauce but
who's getting
46k sorry I need to look up at
a fricking like strategy or something
right now what
46k are you
joking me
I found the secret
oh he found the secret chat
sounds like cheating to me those are
sukyo paths
people with a lot of patience
are practice
honestly don't know how you can do that without a cheat
yeah that seems insane some people are that
I mean I'm sure there's
probably some sort of hidden method
right there boom get right
okay and then just shove everything
to the side of this
okay
yeah
I don't know how to do this
put the cherry there then it can come
off the wall baby
oh no I blocked off that strawberry
I wasn't using oh
are we going to do that
but how it did
I can't remember
sukyo is a drug in Japan
I wonder if it's because it's like such
a nice casual experience like you don't
have to try hard it's not like you log in
you like waste all your like progression
or whatever it's not like that
it's just like you can open it up
sit down and have a
just some casual fun honestly
so I was a bit folk or so mean about casual gamers
but
casual gamers are eating well sorry they are
like
maybe we were too hasty
maybe we shouldn't have judged
I can't tell if gimli just meowed
or there's
a note in this game that sounded like a cat meowing
in my brains like gimli
right we'll put the orange here
cause we're gonna get I know oh well
talk about hashtag predictions
okay there's an orange there
then we do that
and then we do this one
and then put orange here
and then we've got yellow
it's like match three games in facebook
mums stop that
that's a little too real
remember when the statistics came out about
who's the biggest populace in gaming
and it was like
because of like games like farmville
and candy crush
women overall are like the biggest
player base
because of those statistics
I remember reading it and it was like
oh my
what happened
I don't know what happened but I'll take it
and it was like oh my god
I can't believe it
it was like women over four
are the biggest gamer
literally and I was like holy shit
we need to like level up gamers
holy crap
that's so cute
okay we already got telly
we orange
becomes other orange
then orange and orange becomes cherry
becomes lemon
let them get up
right we're gonna put the purple here
and then we're gonna put the orange here
and then we're gonna put the grape here
you're not grape you're a strawberry
oh no I don't want to
separate them too much and then two oranges
make a telly and then an orange
okay I think I'm getting the order
things a little bit
it'd be better
but
I'm getting it maybe
I'll speak a little too soon but if you
wow
you're not a real gamer if you don't speak too
I'm strategising
only match two if you dare
my mum was really good at tetris and when she found the tetris battle royale game
she was hurt honestly
I would know my mum plays
those whenever she has downtime
and developed a worse gaming addiction
than me
I think the sims doesn't count as games
oh that is the hot take
I
kinda used to be like that
where I was like oh that's not a real game
but then I was like you know what
let people have fun
like
if people are happy playing a game I'm just happy
they kinda have like something
they have something like downtime wise
I think I don't know I just think it's sweet
I just think it's nice
okay
what did that do for me
exactly
that is exactly
why I didn't want to put that damn cherry there
it's pushing the peach up though
okay
okay some things are
moving
I don't know if I want to put it inside there
that's what she said
don't say such things
it's first thing in the morning in refland
okay there I think that was probably the better idea
rather than to separate
oh no
put the orange there
all according to plan
I can't believe we're literally strategizing
on a freaking fruit game
right if those two
cherries can kiss up there
that would be cute
what was if he kissed
what was if he did wiggle of kitten
the sims isn't giving every girl all 400
US dollars worth it
bruh I think his are paid for the DLC
and I was like are you joking me
just fucking message me next time a DLC comes out
oh wait she said hi to me
she said hi to me in the end
okay
one second
okay everything's fine
I thought something went
exploded no I'm just kidding
right let's try again focus up
we are gamers
we know how to game
for the most part
stop giving me the wee ones
please
if I wanted them to go there
I would have put them there
not the cherry that accidentally
fell down there blocking
the big apple
come on
I thought this game was supposed to be easy
your gamers still have leveled up
gain strategizing well I've literally just backfired
in 4k how dare you curse me
right now
literally just backfired horrifically
right you too
finally right if those peaches can kiss
please kiss
they look like mochi balls
mochi balls mochi balls
mochi balls
gotta catch them all
that's not what that is
right okay
okay okay
okay let them get up let them get up let them get up
stop
giving me cherries and strawberries
sorry I'm about to become cherries in 4k
it keeps giving me the wee ones
which makes my game harder
stop
getting me the wee ends
right I'm gonna put this here
and then I'm gonna roll
oh well I literally ruled the orange thing
right
what does that mean
what does it mean
will someone please
think about what it means
okay there's things moving
you're allowed to move
I give you permission to move
just as I give you permission to breathe
right that's gonna create an apple
on the top left
if that apple kisses a lemon
it becomes a peach which kisses that peach there
so that's fine
so we're gonna put an orange here
on purpose
and then we're gonna roll
for an orange
wait
oh
why am I born like
this
okay there we go there we go
sorry I did it I'm so sorry
I don't know why I'm born like this
I don't know
why I'm born like that
seriously I literally say the strategy out loud
and then my brain's like do you want to do this
and I'm like sure
no
stop
how did I get them to touch
oh my god
actual strategy I can't believe it
thinking about and planning your next move
helps
this can't be true
no I was gonna hope
they would touch the orange in time
I can't believe it
wait things are moving
I need things to settle before I can start planning
is that cantaloupe it is
the thing is
why this game gripped the beach
you're for nearly a year what a melon
and then I'm allowed to go okay
that's when I have permission
we are purely morals living
in a world for a single cow
fish
you love this cow fish
shadow wizard money gang
those
oops
I did that again
sorry
I'm talking to a modeler right now
we done
and no not for gentoo
fucking relax it's not for a gentoo modeler
relax relax
production isn't confirmed before anyone starts going
sorry I should have given more context to that
since
relax relax relax
no not gentoo
not yet
relax relax relax
relax relax no not gentoo
relax relax
I've got a few artworks of the girls coming
through which I'm actually really excited about as well
just like selab
selab baratory
wait is it actually that hard to get
or is it hard to get
because of who I am
because of the type of person I am
thank you tiny spiny
wait gentoo modeler relax
no oh my god
I've not even been at it two months
I'll be at you for two months
no
no production gets confirmed
during my donor con
azuras is coming up and then shebes is coming up
and then
and then what
um
and then me
and october
wait gen 69
stop I could have sworn
someone said something like I can't wait for the spin-off
gen
when strawnee realises she wants to like
help out more people or something like that
shit you got me
I was like fuck that's who clean and sinker
right there
don't stay down thank you for the extended membership
by telling me to relax I'm now very stressed
I'm sorry I don't mean to
like that
um
yeah but I kind of got who cleaned and sinkered
I'm not gonna lie you got me there
you got me there right I want this
apple to become
yellow
stop giving me cherries
I can't do anything with them
I'm just like spamming them down I'm like
what do you want from me
okay I should probably be strategizing
right now but right I'll strategize
with that move okay and then watch this
uh-huh or yeah or yeah oh sugar
I want to do an apple with it well
not gonna lie I think this
runs over
unless
okay we've got a bit of breathing room
but not enough
a thousand years of strongy don't
be able to grow as big as a whole
are you joking I ain't got that kind of money
I ain't got that kind of money partner
she gaming it may be over
on the bright side high score
it is look at my high score it's
2000 I've not had 2000
before
right you boom boom boom okay good
oh oh no did that mean
to push them apart
oh I think it's over I can't
really see a strategy
nope it's a straw
it's a strawberry
I keeps giving me
wee ones I'm actually
gonna start raging
stop giving me
wee ones please I'm begging
begging you
I can't do it yeah I was
gonna say it's gonna pop okay
2113 though
I'm literally so freakin happy
okay
top score high score
3 that's not but I'll take
that hell yeah why don't I get a round of applause
for this one though it gives me a round
of applause for my terrible attempt
but this time
it's like right alright then
alright then
that's what I thought that's what I thought
give me a round of applause yeah yeah I did good
a bit my high score
we start we start we start
surely we can get a watermelon
before stream has to end surely
surely
surely green eggs and ham
that I actually need to strategize
I kind of don't want to use my brain though
ummmm
kind of don't want to use my brain
nah
right we want to shove those
together
right just fine bomb that's
fine then you there
then you there
then you here
sorry I'm actually sweating
betting on a 5 hour stream
no I can't
see normally this would
devolve into a 5 hour stream naturally
but cause my dad's here
we're going out today
to a cafe again
mommy's mail in live
what just happened I believe
thank you Kaidon I hopefully believe too
I do not believe
but I believe oh no did I just break
my game
did I just break my input
no did I just break my input
I broke my I broke my input
are you serious
no I broke my input
cause I'm freaking streaming off the end
gato hold on
hold on hold on hold on
look at another music just
like casually caressing us in the background
hold on hold on hold on
nope that's not it
hold on I can't believe I broke that are you serious
why are you if I broken the L gap
where the fuck is it
why are you acting like
I'm not doing input right now
I have no idea
I'm gonna close it and open it again
and if it doesn't pop up
I think the stream's over unironically
hold on
um
open
oh my god
oh my god I'm so smart
but now it's not full screen
why is it not full screen
hold on let me make it full screen
and then I'll show off
alright how the fuck did I make this full screen
you can totally see I'm having to
right so the way the freaking L Gato
works is in order for me to see the gameplay
I have to capture it be a fucking
movie what maker
I know I was so scuffed
I was so scuffed I was the only way I could figure out
how to be able to see my stream
whilst I play the game
and capture it to you at the same time
but it's not freaking full screen anymore
I think I'm just gonna have to manually capture it
don't look don't look
I know I know it's got
stop stop looking hold on let me fix it
let's see like watch this
I'm gonna close the bottom see oh oh
you don't see nothing oh you can't tell
that I'm totally in a movie
thing
a movie capture
yeah the L Gato is a bit funny I have to admit
but as long as the L Gato
there we go boom oh
look oh nothing
but nothing but net there we go
wait is that
oh look at that
you can't even tell
I mean you can tell a little bit but you can't even tell
perfect what are you talking about
what are you on about that I'm using
really scuffed mechanics just to record
the screen consumption
of soap oh my god
what is this
they go against each other
the smartest cut a pre-recorded gameplay
stop could you imagine
if I was reacting to like pre-recorded stuff
and be like oh my mum's got
a leaflet
please tell me a vtuber has been found out
for doing that it will make
my day I'm not kidding
please tell me a vtuber has been
exposed for reacting to gameplay that
isn't theirs please
I'm on man's knees tell me the juicy gossip
I need to know
yeah I
miss oh kiss kiss kiss
they kiss
I love when you kiss
yes
oh my god we love physics engine
out here shadow wizard buddy game
I don't know if a vtuber for streamers definitely
done it yeah yes actually though
it was more played by someone else
that has given
me peace in my life
I can now continue on amen
also if there's any lurking
bleeding hearts
why is it when I go into Azura's stream
she's reviewing your fucking goon caves
pff
any bleeding hearts want to defend themselves
from the accusations are you just gonna take it
because
yeah you got
you got got
no I'm not fucking good at ring
camp panties
thank you for the tip
Bob
they're not pre-recorded
stop
thank you tiny spiny
wait what stream did we think it was pre-recorded on
thank you Bob for stealing my panties
I'm not wearing pantyloons as well
see Bob actually knows I'm wearing pantyloons
it's so weird wearing clothes
I'm gonna say I've actually
I've kind of gotten used to wearing clothes at this point now
but it is rather odd
I'm not really that used to it yet
okay
purple can go there
but strawberry and cherry has to go over here
and then this is all gonna pop
oh my god I'm actually using my head for once
ah
if I put too strawberry
on this side
that will become a purple thing and it'll be happy
oh well nope I've just
absolutely messed myself up doing that
nice one
you want to try that again? no? do you just want to ruin the entire gameplay?
yeah okay well as long as you're having fun
yeah thanks brain
no
the game knows exactly
where I put that
right
okay that was actually really lucky
okay okay okay
let him get up
right we're gonna put this over here
and then we're gonna put the orange one right here
and then we're just gonna throw all the stuff down here
until we get what we want
okay we're here for something in particular
we're not gonna go until we get it
do I make myself clear?
exactly that's what I want
boom boom boom boom
oh you can kiss
it's okay don't be shy
yeah it's only a save for work
are you sure AC is the feral one?
honestly oh we actually got a cantaloupe
like so early on
I guess the baby pit
strategy
the kiss
a few of you have been
confessing in my marshmallow that you get a bone bone when I kiss
and I'm like you shouldn't have told me that
I've got too much power now
okay
you've given me too much power
you have
I did not put it on that say
don't
things are popping
probably lack under rapid
right that's clearly not gonna touch
anything but that is there
who's leaking
what is marshmallow?
marshmallow is a way you can anonymously talk
to me
and leave me like questions about stuff
you want me to answer
or things you would like me to do for the girls
that kind of thing
or stuff that you would like to look out for
or look forward to
or stream suggestions as well
you can like straight up tell me what you want me to play
a lot of
reeflings may not realise that you guys
actually I can't believe I'm gonna say this
your guys' opinion
squeezed me quite strongly
I'm not gonna lie
you guys
opinionated
wait we're actually on a decent run
sorry don't jinx it
if I put a cherry here
that's fine
I'm gonna have to sacrifice
oh I need to think
I'm actually having to use my
oh no things start moving my plan goes out the window
right
oh my god right okay okay it's fine
it's fine
just let it happen
okay I think this is gonna have to
be the sacrifice side now
unless I put the orange one there
no why would you do something
like that
why would you betray me like that
I'm strategising so hard right now
and this is how you repay me
this is how you repay me
I'm actually getting trolled in this game
we have influence
reeflings stay winning
wow that's a big one
I'm proud to admit I'm one of those fellow reeflings
against a sudden richness
I don't know if you're littered
I mean you're littered but
right
if I put these two down here
I get an orange okay
I need one more orange and then that
I'm having to sacrifice this entire
side
ah right
oh I'm having to sacrifice
this entire side for a payoff
hopefully
okay we got yellow what did yellow become
I need a second yellow
I'm in trouble
okay orange I'll take it
then a cherry
and then a mix
okay we've got an apple
we just need one more apple and then the peaches
will kiss
and then life will be hunky dory
I repeat life will be hunky dory
any hunky doryers
no
oh is that gonna be
are we gonna be okay
I think we're okay
I think
okay
draft hold on
am I gonna have to roll for an orange
on the left side
I'm gonna roll
for an orange
unless the game does that
which you're not really supposed to do that
because I wasn't actually planning on you doing that
it's three game for me and I'm
not sleeping till you get a war
the pressure jeez I ain't that good at the game
alright we've got an orange
we're gonna pop it right here
and we're just
gonna do the throw method
because we need to roll for an orange
okay it's starting to backfire
I repeat it's starting to backfire
okay okay okay okay okay
yeah
see this game
I literally did so much
effort and work
to get nowhere and in the end
it didn't even matter
right there right and then go down go down
go down no no
please
please go down
mr. peach
mr. peach please
why apple why is nothing
sucking towards each other go touch each other
right now jeez
oh that peach
the throw method
doesn't work
I tried so high
r slash no context
wait what is
kiss kiss no no
the peach
isn't as heavy as Johnny's peach
real true
evidence to back up
right here
I've just thrown this again
worked out we would have been laughing
but we're not laughing we're crying
can we just can I get like an extension
can I like download a mod that extends the box
by like five pixels
literally give me a tiny bit more room to breathe
I'm not even kidding
oh I'm not even using my brain anymore
oh that's right in brainless
and I'm fucking up the entire
gameplay
I
have done it
now I've done it now
right kiss
kiss what are you
gonna have to kiss yeah oh and it killed me
okay
right okay okay okay it's fine
I literally you know that little
I sounded like one of those
sand mammals from
Star Wars please tell me
you guys heard that too the wee thing that goes
wow
I've forgotten what they're
called yeah clap clap kiss
oh I kill me
they're not called one for that so the hairy
tusky things that look like
um
willy mammoths but different
this is probably been said before
but the hair pattern activating when the avatar
bugs is kinda crazy oh it's my sleep toggle
are you ready
this is my sleep toggle
when I go to sleep
I hypnotize you so you don't attack me
because I'm a cuttlefish and I'm actually quite edible
if you want to get really technical
but that's my sleep
but I can put I can manually put my hair
on my hypno pattern
hi I'm
I'm a cuttlefish by the way I know
I don't know hypnosis often but I promise
I'm working on it I just need time
I'm working on my hypnosis stream
did you just leak that you're doing a stream
dedicated to hypnosis yes I did
I'm writing a script
for it so I don't mess up though
okay let's sweat
let's sweat I wanna make you sweat
I will say one thing against this game
I am gonna slander this game slightly
so if this is your favourite game please do close
your ear holes
it's only fun when things are going
your way but when things aren't going your way
it's just frustrating
oh my god
actually that just
reminded me I saw a comment on my YouTube
this morning someone went
this is the most casual Elden Ring player
I've ever seen and obviously
it was a stream where I was summoning all you guys
in to do the work and I'm like
oh well yeah that's kind of the point
I get to have fun with my reeflings
I was giggling I'm sure
they were like oh my god let's see if this VTuber
is any good at Elden Ring
maybe and like hi reeflings
can the reeflings do it
oh you can do it like halfway across the map
with my crossbow ball spraying
and missing everything
honestly I was giggling away
I was like brrr you've come to the wrong streamer
if you're looking for skills
literally making reeflings play the game for it
whilst I'm like shoving food in my face
my favourite is that a reefling
gave me that crossbow ball that sprays
and then I missed all my shots
but won
and like you guys were giving me like
runes to level up in that
I think when we go back to Elden Ring
we'll play the base game to activate Ranny
and then
we'll go and do the DLC
and enjoy it because I was kind of speedrunning through it
I didn't mean to speedrun through it
but just like
I knew we were up against the Vaude
at 12 hours so I'm like
okay what's next show me what's next
reeflings type thing
but I think we need to maybe slow it down
and enjoy ourselves
like I said we're not in a major rush
as if those are crisscross applesauce
and right now
right I've got orange
I'm wondering
I bet you if I just spammed down the middle
I'd actually get more points than
when I actually try hard in the game
I'm looking forward to more Elden Ring
I'm glad you are
yeah
I am looking forward to
doing the DLC
more of it because
I don't actually know what's up ahead
all in all in those
like the classic lines like put these
full of shambushes to rest
just popping in real quick
I'm doing shit but I'm in the game
I'm doing absolutely amazing in real life
although I'm a bit sad because
my dad's going home
soon and it feels like we've not
really done anything fun together
like we've been to cafes
we've been on a few car journeys
but like the weather's
absolute rubbish
like it is rubbish
we're capital R
and
so we haven't really been able to do anything
and it just feels
not like it's a waste because he gets
like a holiday offer working that
but yeah it's just a bit
he wants me to learn to drive
like excuse me
every time
do you not see my amazing bike out there
that bike cost me like
300 dollars and it doesn't
cost any fuel
I don't have to do maintenance I don't have to pay road tax
like I'm sorry but why would I learn to
drive when my bike gets me from A to B
so I'm actually a bike simp I don't care what anyone says
I'm here for my bike
I love my bike I love riding bikes
okay I said it
I said it I love
I freaking love my bike I do
it makes me happy
okay
so no it's those papa cuttles
but I'm legit not learning to drive
I'm reading I miss trains
she's just like me for real for real
I'm sorry I'm like so much fun on my bike
and like I get to feel the wind through my hair
and I get to like I don't know
I think I appreciate it because I'm aware that like
not everyone's in good enough health to like ride
a bike and I get to like have a fantastic
time like the wind sweeps
through my hair I get from A to B like so fast
I don't have to like
be on like I don't go on roads
because it's too dangerous for me to be on a road
so as illegit as even on the bike I would get
mowed down in like milliseconds
and because I'm just so bad
oh that was I didn't even
I'm just rambling I'm being honest
I'm not really playing right now
and
like I'd literally get hit by a car
so quickly if I was on the road so I'm not
and I go on the pavements okay I said what
I said I go on the pavements what you're gonna do about it
fart exactly
stop giving me tellies and stuff
oh there's an orange oh no I should have
put orange there oh well
look
it wouldn't be me if I wasn't
messing it up every two seconds that's when
you know it's legit gameplay for me
I get paid to bike you get paid
to bike to work
is that a thing what can't
well don't dox yourself but
what country would offer that
what country would offer cycle to work
and get paid
I've not heard about it in Scotland
I'm not heard about it in Australia either
the Netherlands it's default Germany
no
I know sorry sorry
reflink don't want to
I'm mailman
Netherlands
okay so here's a dodge
I'm so sorry
reflink but not you being the most stereotypical
I ride a bike and I'm dodge
I'm so sorry
but that you can get more stereotypical
than that that's hilarious
oh bless your cotton socks that's amazing
oh you must be so healthy though
some German companies do it but it's really rare
sound fish not to be confused
with them for this
thank you for becoming a member and to support
your profile picture is terrifying
it looks like a shark that's like angry
why is this got muscles
why is it got musclies
my guess is courier
I've been watching oh my god
I've been making my dad watch delivery videos
I watch a guy
I think his name's like
London eats or something like that
and he like does episodes where he
oh I've randomly got peach
he like does episodes where he like
cycles around London delivering
and he shows you like how much money he makes
and I just find it fascinating that like human
powered stuff can like result in money
I don't
so I find a lot of concepts
hard to like accept
not accept but to make heads
I'm completely messing this up
focus right purple that's fine
purple can go there wait what's going on
something things are moving around
why is the peach being shoved up
did that help
or did that hinder I think that might have hindered
I'm not gonna lie
I think I might be in trouble
no I was gonna
put that in there
oh my god sorry
I've done nothing but ramble this entire time
oh surprise surprise the one
are you serious right now
why are you levitating
oh
what do I need to
no
this game is such a
troll
please push it over
no just
throw trying to push it over
it's fine
it's a child's game
don't ever
don't ever play that
mp3 file again to me
what was that
don't the disrespect
of this game
the disrespect to go
no
don't ever play that game again
that sound again to me how dare you
right I'm gonna just do
a method okay I'm just gonna do a method
please
you didn't like the clapping so it did that instead
I am going to spam
and see if I can get more than 1,300
points just I'm just gonna
test it out I'm sure it's been tested a billion
times before
applause for 1,200
but a minimum for one
I'm just gonna test it out
I'm just gonna test it out let me test
okay
testing testing
I'm just spamming it
I mean stuff is
I was joking about
I would be better off just not even thinking
and putting it through but
the allegations
I might not be beating them
things are
things are mashing together by accident
she's gonna cry when she gets
not we've already got a peach
bruh
okay okay I think it's gonna stop
working because we've got a variety going now
but
we're at 300 points without
even saying bruh
we're at
500 points without trying I swear
if I beat my record doing
a tactic like this
we're almost at 600
we're at 600 points
okay okay
okay it's fine
we're at 700 but we're literally
almost half of my record
by not trying
hold up
is this for real
why did this kind of work though
why did this kind of
work though
right
will I actually try and play
I literally got
1000 not trying are you serious
is this like a secret method
that I've just discovered or is this like
everyone already knows this
okay things are
bruh
am I gonna make
more score
am I gonna beat
my record no
no tell
it's not true
okay
okay right I was gonna say
right I'm kinda glad that I threw there
I didn't mean to throw I meant to push that apple to the side
so it would come together
no way
that was amazing
oh my god
I'm not gonna lie
I think that might have actually
I'm sorry
I'm so sorry
can I try that again I wanna try it again
but put it in the corner
blame RNG
honestly I wanna put it in the corner
this time
1300 points to spam
I was literally
200 off my third place
no way this is the
freaking methods
I refuse
just spam it down
and like here's me try hard
in trying to strategize and you're telling me
I can just spam and then deal with it on the other end
random chance the only thing in this world
that is fair and biased
it won't be as effective in the corner
because there's less randomness for the fruit
to sort by size
it could be a viable strategy until you get
a certain fruit then
you can be more strategic
accidental
sort and strike
literally the game's just dealing with itself right now
the game's like here let's help out
what we at
300 okay it looks like the corner doesn't work
but the middle seems to work way better
yeah the corner isn't
like I'll move over
if it's gonna
no way
I'm stunned
that's
that's outrageous
sorry that's legit outrageous
okay I'll move
to the other corner just not to throw
like ray of the end
okay
well I think I'm gonna have to do it in the middle then
I'm not allowed to do strategy
well she says that she moves it to the side
nothing else pot okay
literally 800
I need to spam over
spam in different areas hold on
let me cure it
no way
I'm about to get a thousand score for not even trying
well we're full now
we're full at the end
jesus mary and joseph
we're full
she's hacking
good afternoon please don't look at my gameplay
hi mefling
okay right never actually gonna try
but the fact
that that kinda
did so well has me concerned
I am mildly taken concerned
oops oh well
she says that she try hard and completely messes up
full of fruits hopefully not full of
that terrible joke you're getting booed right now
actually you get booed terrible joke
try again go back to the drawn room
I say that as if I'm not the
funniest fucking streamer alive
honestly I have nothing but the audacity sometimes
thank you for putting up with me reflings
okay
and then swabby
and then this one
and that one
then kiss okay
then put it in the middle
put the wee ones to the side
and then put what one they are
and that one they are
and put it in a window
wow
oh my god good rng hello
well terrible rng because it decided to do that
to me I feel personally
attacked by this rng
please do not ever cook again
thank you right
if we get an apple
can you say apple
apple
uhhhh
just need an apple
just need a wee
a wee orange
will do it to be honest
okay yeah an orange like that
will do it
and then
I guess take I don't want to risk it
I'm doing the method where I throw everything
down the side until I get what I want
and of course the apples can't touch now
so that's like
the apple
actually I'm doing a karaoke stream
soon I hope you're ready for it
my dad literally leaves and then I start streaming
out the wazoo again I'm gonna be so depressed
so
hey apple stop that's what's been
literally tearing on the tip
of my tongue for ages
and I don't want to start it because my brain's gonna start it
cut an ear with oh I didn't mean
to put that down well
hey
literally one of the first thing I notice
when I got sent to stream of yours is how funny
we're not hating your frustration when bothered in a game
oh me just raging
in the game this is unplayable
I can't play this
yeah yeah that's my streamer right there
are you joking
actually the terrible thing
that's funny though I'll take it
things are moving
I promise I'm not throwing I just don't know
where to put the cherries
god I have so many yellow
melon
can you become peaches
peaches peaches peaches
peaches
peaches peaches
I'm
making you mine
I have still yet to see the super mario
movie do you guys want to watch it together
or is it doodoo caca
is that a bad film
should we watch it together
cherries go in your mouth not finishing that
actually
wait is that a reference I don't know
hold on a minute internet reference that I
don't know about
is decent
what moving out no no not right now
I don't have time until my dad
goes but I have a lot of time once my dad
goes
it's not bad I mean it's
alright
I liked it a lot it's kind of mid
but I'll watch anything with you
aww reflin
does my does my dry
commentary like increase
the oh no
hmm
look at that cherry just
spinning down there he's having the tame of
his life mario movies
worth watching the super mario is good
I'd say it's just silly fun jack black kills it
as in a good way like oh he killed that
role he he slayed
yes slay
slay jack
slay your enemies
oh things are poppin
things are kissing kissing
okay okay okay let's not throw
let's not throw
I mean it's the same on both sides really
other than that one's a blockade
but
it's my blockade to make
um
things are moving slightly
things are experiencing gravity
the laws of
gravity
in the world
is turning
inside out
you
200 degrees
that's not the words at all
and hard to see
so don't
stop the fruit
now
don't
stop kissing fruit together
because they're having a good time
having a good time
they wanna kiss all the time
come on fruit keep kissing
right now kiss
harder kiss even
harder no well
maybe no
that probably wasn't what I wanted
keep kissing little
fruits and then you will be
rewarded beyond your mortal comprehension
yeah oh
things are getting a bit stuck around this
kind of loop
sorry
that was bizarre I don't know why I made that noise
I'm so sorry
I'm trying to think but it's hard
I'm having to use my brain for once
see this is where I want you guys to remote
into my pc and then play it for me
and I'll just commentate because you guys will be so much
better than me at it
your karaoke stream gonna go hard
I hope you're ready for it
mommy's kissing school is
the war
right now
school's in session
an appropriate teacher
win
I've put that in the complete wrong area
I beat my record
oh no
you have to kiss
unironically you have to kiss
the best way to spend my
thank you dear little lover
yes I'm gonna do a public karaoke stream
and then I'll do
membership let me stretch sorry I need to stretch
by stretch I mean I'm trying to stall
for time because those two should be kissing
you literally just did
an appropriate teacher yeah and did you pass
my class yes you did
you passed whilst I passed
your cross state
thank you for coming to my TED talk
hi hi
you got a license for that tongue
are you squidding me right now
pass the weed
hi I'm fruit can we kiss
wait why did you tape it like that
with the TH
come here little piece of fruit
see I should be saving this for the
industry but I'm not you're welcome
when other streamers would deny
you I entertain
thank you for the tip boy and thank you
for the tip dealer lover
any dealer lover
two lovers
forbidden from one another
a war to
vain
it's so ogre it's so ogre
those apples need to kiss
kiss
are you squidding me right now
yes oh that didn't really help
oh he bought a cup should I show you
the cup he bought I bought myself a tea
spoon holder
we went into like this shop that just
sells like knick-knack periwack give a dog a
bones thank you the afro fluff
for the super chat
and he bought himself a cup to take
home and I bought myself a little
tea thingy my bobber
where you put your tea spoon on because I make
tea like all day long all I do is drink
tea I'm sorry I'm actually addicted
but like in a good way because it helps my
throat and stuff okay that was good
I'll take that and we're going to get a
round of applause the game isn't going to play
boo.mp3 so I'll take
that okay I'll take
that we've got third place now
I'm not gonna look
we're not going to be submitting my score
to the fucking
the
speedrun thing yeah damn right
you better clap for me
yeah that's right strongy has entered the
rankings
monthly rankings this game wants me to play
monthly I think I'm
a bit too much of a born streamer
are you squinting me right now
yeah thank you
thank you for clapping
will I clap back for you
what was that in my hands
oh I need to buy twitter premium
actually so I can start uploading that stuff
hold on let me write that down
let me write that down
I need to fucking write that down on my notes
buy twitter
premium
and post
audios you can't put on youtube
go okay as in my notes
I literally
wrote that down wrote that down
okay
I'm tempted to try the spam method
I'm so so I'm so tempted
are you squinting me right now
thank you I don't fit a tip
the only fruit I want to see her kiss is a banana
is it your banana reflex
that's right I will kiss you
with the theme song of this game in the background
slaysaber I really
like the strongy web pvp
yeah you're like well I like making them
sorry some people hate it but I'm like
it's so fun to pretend to have a wee winky
sorry like
you can't even tell me you didn't want my winky
I didn't believe you
I promise I'm actually using a method right now
this is real I'm using a method
I'm tempted to actually just spam
until the industry I'm not even kidding
this is so fun I love this spam method
because I don't actually have to use my brain
or be tactical
sorry this is a gameplay that I'm here for
not having to think
not having to think look all of us can just
ink and none of us have to think
that's the way I like it
stop being so blatant
I've been so blatant recently
why am I getting limited ads on some of
my streams
I don't mean this
no wonder you like Sigmund Freud
stop
are you squinting me right now
oh you give me a pun
what's the cantaloupe underscore cool
underscore cool
thank you for the super chat
and the pun Hylia
you mean sister in law that's so specific
you know who else I'm
sisters in law with
and on sister
you're not a refling sister huh
okay I think I've boled
I think I've bolzed it up
I've bolzed up my tactic
unless the game said
Hail Mary full of grace the Lord is with thee
sorry I shouldn't use that
blasphemous terms
uh
then again Jesus hung out with slag so
I won't take any slag slander how do you
I won't take any slander
that's hilarious
stop right stop I'm getting too excited playing this game with you
I'm actually getting like hype as fuck
for playing but not playing at the same time
kiss
I'm not even trying
how
I mean I'm loving it I'm here for it
if I put the orange theirs are gonna bounce off
yeah it bounces off of course it does because why wouldn't it
okay okay okay
hit him with a him with a
right we're gonna put that there and then we're gonna put purple here
oh no I could have
oh no this can't be I messed up
but it's okay
I mess up often but just because you mess up
it doesn't mean you're not allowed to keep trying
like geez
don't judge yourself so heavily remember
you look at yourself through a lens heavier
than anyone else ever does
only you'll notice things that make you cringe
but people will never think about it in their life ever again
so don't be afraid to be cringe
it's okay big bros you can tell
me how much you
sorry
that was so specific
right
what happens here okay that's fine
we can deal with that
okay that's fine and then we're gonna put an orange here
then we're gonna put
a thing
literally the big bros been worried about
engaging with Amy and I'm like
bro I literally made her
well I made her lore
but everything else she does
is by her own accord
I do not tell the girls to do nothing
so
I don't know why you're cringing
be free be yourself
to be cringe is to be free unironically
as I said you're the only person
that will ever care
and look at yourself through
such a severe lens
just enjoy life
literally unironically you'll know
please mr. Apple
you do this to me every time
you actually do this to me
every time I'm starting to think it's
are you
that can't be right I'm being
trolled
well someone better
start moving because I'm not playing
another go
someone better start moving
because it's no me
okay
aha
I'm in trouble
a strover actually
I do like damn apples
oh
I was actually pretty good
I'll give you that
I blinked in the box got filled
these are just high player strats
your brain just can't comprehend
how MLG Pro
what's up scrawny
me sucking at this game
what's that
no stop showing me the rankings
I'm getting embarrassed how much I'm being
outplayed by these rankings seriously
I mean
there's nothing I can do
I've made everything worse
okay
right one more give me one more chance
surely I can get watermelon
before the industry surely
no don't play that
freaking SFX I don't know fucking far
SFX I don't even know what I would call that
right
this method clearly works I don't care
what anyone says oh my god they're stacking
so pretty
I actually enjoyed the way they were stacking
just one more just one more
give me one more just one
more chance
I don't know the words
but don't that's not gonna stop me
far
hard
scored.mp3
literally you could have done worse
honestly this method works
I think I just suck that this method
works so well for me
I mean obviously
naturally things will start
pop a lock in so I guess
like it's only bound to happen
but it's just like
use brain
or just have fun
spamming
and things work out in the end
okay maybe not this one the RNG on this one
maybe maybe not
oh no they oh
oh
okay I'm happy
please get the watermelon I want to sleep
no no replaying you can go to sleep
there's no way I'm getting the watermelon
I want the watermelon
oh yeah it's all coming together
it's working what do you mean
okay it kind of
doesn't work near the end where I have less room
yeah unless like things
start doing that then
I mean things are shuffling about though
like maybe I just need to give it time to like
talk about
well stuff is happening
wow
like things are
popping and locking
you know
that's what I should do just spam it at the start
and then actually try hard at the end
being like oh yeah no no I was trying hard in the whole time
what are you talking about
I was trying hard in the whole time
this is pure skill
sorry I'm watching myself play on OBS
I'm not even looking forward like this
I'm like that's not a view
who let her cook
it's working okay I'm not in the kitchen all the time
but it's actually working for real
so it's
yeah okay it's working until it's not
don't play the far I will
literally mute the in-game audio
don't think I won't
maybe spam to halfway or the first pineapple
okay okay okay okay I'll hear you
I'll hear you that might work
right until we get the spam until we
get a pineapple
okay spam until
we get pineapple and then I'll take over
and actually use my brain deal
deal
okay pineapple I'm coming
for you
RNG gods
you better be with me
okay they actually
kind of are with me for real
nothing like accidentally
bumping off of each other
there's a bump in right we've got
cantaloupe we're about to get peach
oh until unless I did that
then that was a bit selfish of me but hey
I'm late no don't worry
I'm gonna redirect
shebeaz away shit
I'm not gonna redirect I'm redirecting to
me even though it's like
three hours away
it's a zero maybe if a zero's waiting room's
off I'll redirect into a zero's waiting
room because we're gonna play
forever early if she comes online
she's not online right now
she's passed out sleeping
mama azuz currently
me me me me
me me me
maybe I should
like let it relax
into stuff because I just blocked
myself from doing something there and I'm like
if I let it relax
then
yeah
I
also have a collab with AC coming up
I convinced her to play a puzzle game with me
she's like no I don't want to play a puzzle
game and I'm like
oh but it's easy AC don't worry
I'll carry you through and she's like
I'll find them strong
even so I've got that
to look forward to
and then
I just need to collab with Shebe and
Emi and then I've at least done a one on one
collab with everyone and viewer
which was my goal
and
okay I balls
that up no
why does it work sometimes
and then other times it doesn't
things are rubbing and touching
but nothing's popping and locking you know what I'm saying
wait
something's happening whoa
okay
we're moving
now if the peaches can kiss
do it kiss right now
no it's pure aren't you
lowly monster
why is AC on the make
she's so adorable
I love her
okay okay we got pineapple as I said
I'm trying to try harder now
and orange so we want it to land on top
of the apple which of course
due to how small brain
I am that didn't work
that's okay
now we have an orange
next which we're actually
I think we're forced to play it
I think we're forced to play it here to make an
apple oh no
but it's not heavy enough
no
please yes okay
no what
I don't think we can do anything
I think we're just in trouble
oh
hold on
can I get you to like
I'm gonna have to put it in the middle
if I put
an orange
here
of course it gives me a freaking orange
after that are you serious
it gives me two
the RNG gods clearly
hate me it's okay you can
see it with your chest
right let's try that
this isn't gonna work
it's ogre
no why is this game so hard
why is this so hard
the game just pushed me out
no it's gonna play the freaking it
right one more try one more try one more try
it literally pushed me out
any far on me
apple but I didn't know you had
a bikini toggle oh did you just
see my short
I do have a bikini toggle
and
you guys weren't supposed to know
about it until later but I had the key
bindings on my keyboard and I
flashed stream like twice
in a bikini
which was ridiculous
because everyone was like
someone commented they're like oh yeah you totally meant
that by mistake
and I was like no motherfucker
if I meant that on purpose
I would have done it on debut for the easy
fucking clips and clicks like
you're welcome you know that's when
you know it's not fucking staged because I
cannot tell you how many vtubers I've seen
that staged a debut and then
all of a sudden oh no
my clothes disappear
oh it was an accident
and it's like obviously for fucking clicks
like doesn't it be so obvious
I'm sorry
but I don't know if it's because I'm Scottish and I'm so cynical
sometimes
but it's so fucking obvious when someone does that
tactic and I'm like bro you're actually
you're actually so obvious
I don't know why we're pretending otherwise
fine just say you're doing it for clicks
that's how you have you play the freaking
like vtuber game
like bro
I just found it it took so long to
realise oh you guys don't watch my
shorts uh freaking
um Arisa
not Arisa from Overwatch actually
speaking of Overwatch the new character came out
now I don't normally met I don't normally
mess with Overwatch like I've not played it
man
I haven't played it this year honestly
um
that was a primal scream
oh I did not mean
to do it I absolutely did not mean to do it
so if anyone's like oh my god
you posed that you meant that
bro honestly I'm sorry but you have been
brainwrote so far by like
tiktok acting or something
if you're like oh my god you meant that you planned that
bro
I've really
played since over yeah so apparently the new character
is called Juno
and she's a pilot
and she's a healer
anyone wanna play
anyone wanna be my jewel in Overwatch
and I'll be your heal slot
outrageous behaviour stop talking
right now
I don't know when she comes out
but she got announced
um
we have a pineapple
honestly
right
don't give me wee ones
give me big ones
okay we got an apple
can you say apple
stop
we're up gonna re-download
well I think we can do like 10 lobbies
together as well in Overwatch
sorry I know people like to shiz on it
but I mean
it's kind of a good game to stream
snipe on
did I mess that up? I did
that's okay
it's okay cause I like ruining the game
I constantly throw by accident
now if you wanted to claim
I'm thrown on purpose
I'll say that you've got some merit cause I'm so
freaking dumb that I keep doing it
how do I have
three apples
I have four apples
and they were refusing to kiss
please kiss
at your next convenience kiss
right now kiss your sister
right now
okay
kissing
in progress
kissing in progress
kissing kissing kissing
what are these
physics
I don't even know what to do
I don't
I don't I don't know what to do
I'm making this so much worse
this is getting worse and worse
and worse
Todd Howard
because it just works
what
I'm gonna let everything settle
before I start spamming down new stuff
but
okay
if I put the orange here
and then I make another orange
okay
and then I just throw stuff down here
until I get what I want
is that
little fruit gonna
cut me out of what I want I think so
and for that reason
I am strategically
doing it this way
right oh no please don't move the board
no
you were supposed to go down
I'm trying so
hard please
please please don't claim I'm throwing
I'm actually trying so hard
right now
I'm trying so hard
this game can't keep
getting away with it
this is impossible
pokua
pokua why would this game tease me
like this
well this is just a fun little game
that people play it's like
chill and stuff
chill
I'm sweating
I'm gonna run out of room
okay hold on
I need this to pop over here
as if
you give me an orange
you're such a liar
please something kiss right now
the yellow has to kiss
but I blocked it
there's like nothing I can do
and it's riff oh please kiss
what does it become an orange okay
okay I can work with that
can I
not really but
I don't have much of an option
I ain't got room
and nothing is moving
right one more game one more game
one more one more one more one more
this game should have boss music level
so you died right one more one more
one more one more one more
I didn't lose okay I just got hard stuck
fart dot mp3 time honestly
one more right this is the last one
promise promise this is the last one
still no watermelon
literally please go please rest
refilling who's waiting on me to get a watermelon
it's not happening
let me just um
woo soupy until a zero cloud
no I need to go for a nap actually
I'm not awake so I need to sit in a line
but she's not awake right now
come on
come on baby come on baby
come on I can do it I can do it
we can't go out on a loss
I mean we may be I don't know
I don't want to tell you the doubt
who I will say one thing though
I don't think I'm gonna
revisit this game on stream
you're squidding me right now
it's a bit too casual for me
last chance for mommy's melons we're watching
I'm trying I'm trying
let's stuff pop let's stuff pop
there's a few things I need to pop
okay there we go
let it pop let it pop
let it move around right and then once things have settled
I guess we can just spam again
okay okay okay okay okay
there's a good pop when I didn't have to put
any effort into it
pop that there
okay I guess we do the spam method again
actually working
that's all you have to say me
my methods of madness
are working
okay okay uh huh oh yeah uh huh
oh yeah oh yeah me right now
oh I didn't want
thank you Kaidon for the super chat
mag honey thank you for
the extended membership you don't have to
put any effort into me either
oh that sounds so self-deprecating
I hope you mean in a nice way
as in like
wait are you going to do all the work
and I need to be a pillow princess is that what you mean
your strat is kicked
honestly are you winning
no I'm doing piss dem paw
literally 2k is my record
so we're doing this method called I just spam them down the middle
and it's actually
it's actually working
for real for real
I'm not even kidding
it's actually working
oh I think
maybe if I put that down there
okay
I don't really
oh no wait no I should have put that there
oops that was me
I'm just so silly
like that honestly I just love the way I throw this game
every time without fail by accident
I just throw
do you just love it when you watch a streamer and she keeps throwing the game
honestly it's so satisfying
you never find better gameplay
when it comes to throwing the me
okay we got an orange
that's what I want to see
orange go down
good
I'm gonna start on this side a bit
I'm messing this up
horrifically
another orange
oh it pushed it over
okay I'm aim bon
aim bon oh yeah that's right
what are you gonna do about it
aim bon
I'm literally doing a 360 no scope on these fruits
don't take a
if those could have kissed that might have gone a bit better
but hey ho
we believe are we gonna score a touchdown
kill grape play
no no like that
praise the sun and the suika
is this the run
I don't know
I'm try hard and so
right I'm gonna get rid of that
I want an apple there so it's just bing ching
now I'm gonna have to throw a little bit
to get where I want to go
okay
put a cherry there
and we'll put an orange
and then that should turn into an orange
oh well this is
well we're just really
please kiss
are you serious
okay that's exactly what we wanted
okay uh huh
oh yeah uh huh
come on come on
come on
come on ladies
hold on let me check
the chart two strawberries
make a
I think I'm gonna have to put this one over here
that's fine uh huh
right
uh huh
hiya
uh huh uh huh
give it to me baby
and all the girls stay pretty
for a white guy
you know it's kind of hard
just to get along today
shit
they asked for a 13 yeah
instead they drew a 31
they say he's trying too hard
and it's not quite him
that's a pretty thing
give it to me
whoo please don't push me out
that's not very nice you're giving me a heart attack
I'm stressed
I'm stressed I've just resorted to singing now
actually stressed in 4k
okay
uh huh
um
I think I'm out of room
and I can't make anything kiss
if those peaches could have kissed
I mean
shit
that actually wasn't that bad
for the last attempt though
I'm not even mad like I'm not
sorry but my chair can't be mad at that
yeah
there's not much I can do at this stage
it's ogre
it's actually ogre but
god damn did we have a good run
yeah god that was a good run
and I got second place
that was my second place record
that was good
that was so good
I'm not even mad
I'm not even mad I'm raging
but I'm not even mad that was so good
clap clap clap
that was really wasn't that bad
right how would I rate suika
um
if you want my honest opinion
I'm not gonna be playing this again on stream
I'm not gonna be playing this off stream either
it's fine there's nothing wrong with the game
there's absolutely nothing wrong with the game
it's just slightly too casual
I don't know
I say that as if I don't literally get you carrying me
in Elden Ring but
I have to admit even I'm like
I'm squinting me right now
it'll settle with looking at your premade ones
my premade melons how do
how do
right so sheebie isn't on but emi might be on later
let me just check
I'll redirect into her
if she isn't on
then I will
nope she's not on
then Azura I will redirect
into Azura's room
yes okay she does have it off
now we might be an hour early
but if she's still asleep then it'll be the usual time
I know literally sheebie's on vacation
so I can't redirect her to her
emi's just came back she's getting into the swing of things again
there's nothing until you collab with Azura
okay yes
how are you doing
sorry that was a stretch I don't know why I made that so weird
maybe I'm just
I'm a freak
I'm a weird
joke I'm a bit of playdough
I'm getting ready for carry
okay now I'm even freaking got the stream up
in the waiting room for it up
right I'm gonna redirect into Azura's POV
of the collab that's in two hours
I'm gonna go lie down for a nap
mummy did you ever talk about needing permission for a short
yes oh right
okay so reflins be completely
and wholeheartedly honest
you can either use Marshmallow for feedback or not
so on the
vealer youtube channel
the announcement trailer got 100k views
the reason
that it got picked up in
the algorithm
is because it was reported
by a news channel which
is ran by a male
and obviously we follow idle culture
now I was going to do a behind the scenes
talking about how
why your
VTuber goes nuts when they make the news
is because there's a clear correlation
of being on VTuber news
and then like the views or whatever
now I was gonna do a breakdown
short about it however
I didn't want to do it if it would upset anyone
so I do want you to be honest
I don't want me to talk about it
I'm more than happy to just
bend that short idea
but it is talking about VTuber news
and in particular one
that is ran by a guy
which is why the vealer
announcement trailer of the agency
got trending if you can see on the website
it's literally got almost 100k views
so I just
didn't want to do anything that upsets you guys
but I was gonna talk about why your VTuber gets excited
and then I was gonna show like correlation between
the
video getting traction
where it got mentioned
and then why VTubers are so thankful
to be mentioned on the news
it's alright wait why would we get upset
ran by a guy mail on stream
I know we're teasing but I just don't want to do
anything that would upset you guys
but please do use Marshmallow as well
if you'd rather give anonymous feedback
that's more than anything
I'm here for you
you do you
just because it's a bit more of a behind the scenes
on the VTuber aspect than it is
about anything else of that degree
it sounds okay
now if I did it
anyone would freak out about that has bigger problems
person that sounds like I see no issue
yeah it's more like a behind the scenes
angle it's not like oh my god
slob on the knob like it's nothing like that
nah I'm the opposite girls
I want to see men
hmm
it's okay right as long as you guys are sure
I'll make sure it's completely
above board to the best my ability but again
you can use my
Marshmallow as well for a bit of feedback
but it's not focused
around that it's the
the subject title is
why do VTubers get so
excited being mentioned in the news
and then I was going to explain
the Vealer trailer got trending
and then I was going to ask some VTubers
that have been in the news
if they had a correlation
as well
that knob might sound cool
you're overthinking it
I just don't want to upset anyone
what is Marshmallow
Marshmallow is in the link below
in the description below
and you can send me anonymous
remarks now if you don't have Firefox
which has an auto translate thing
you can add on
it's in Japanese
in Japanese
so what I'm hearing is
if you do something newsworthy
and have some evidence that mentions
Vealer
basically Vealer made the news for the first agency
and then the trailer
got trending because it got mentioned
it wasn't trending before
originally I was putting advertisement money to show it off
but then it wasn't needed
go for it the behind the scenes stuff is the best
as long as you guys are okay
I wonder what news it was
Sky News Australia? No
I still think there are people who think
she talks to Marshmallows during her free time
I talk to my Marshmallows
I read my Marshmallows
actually I do have a request for you guys
to send me
to send me stuff
um
what kind of stuff?
when
I want to make some twitter
audios
but I need motivation
and record again
so if you ever wanted to send
some stuff
I mean you can't
and then I could use it
okay
I will leave it there
I'm gonna redirect into Azur's little waiting room
please do watch Azur's P.E.O.V
um
actually you can watch us both at the same time
to see what we're dealing with
I'm an idiot you can literally watch them both at the same time
since we're only talking to each other
um
as long as it's not for Gamba
nyaaa
what's wrong with Baltro?
I like Baltro
Baltro's good
Baltro good game
alright
I'm not being funny
but the girls get
so much more hate words
Marshmallows than I do
I get like one or two
just because I've not been posting on my alt twitter
I think if I start posting on my alt twitter
then
you know I'll start to reap the rewards
if you will
um
so give me let me cook
I've got a few things cooking
but yeah if you wanted to be
motivational for no particular reason
in like a weeks time
feel free to use marshmallows
I'll keep one on the burger and Gamba
and I'll respond to them to get traction
how dare you I can't believe it
right I'll do a compilation soon TM
I just can't do it right now
cause then you really want to start describing
about how I want to be collared and leashed
and like walked around like a dog and then my dad's like
what are you doing?
and I'm like nothing nothing nothing
and I'll start like closing down all my tabs in a panic
yeah no don't really want to
don't really want to do that
rather weird rather strange
okay
um
I will redirect into Azura
but we're both going to be online at the same time
we're either going to be an hour early
or the hour specified
Azura is asleep right now so I'm not going to
you know wake up Azura
I'm not going to be like batter
batter entire room like Azura
time to do puzzle
like no she's asleep
if she's asleep she's asleep
either regular time or one hour earlier
okay but don't worry
you're giffy gibbers later
I'm going to go lie down for a nap
okay I see you soon
thank you for enjoying the fruit game with me
might not be the hypest thing but honestly
pretty coo-ai-ne out there
maybe we should do a drunk stream where I can't
I'm not allowed to go offline until I get a war mill
maybe that would be a funnier twist
but thank you very much little reeflings
please
pucker up as always
um
you like that?
like that?
you like feeling my lips on you?
okay I see you very shortly
I see you later, not tomorrow
tomorrow's after the next stream
I see you later alligator okay
I almost missed that
thank you for becoming a member
thank you
thank you for becoming a member and turning your support
I'm getting a new emote slot
unlocked soon to you at this rate
okay I kiss
I go and I go for a quick nap
okay I go nap beside Azura
she's nice and warm
goodnight
see you later alligator you know
not in a while crocodile and three hours crocodile
it doesn't even
rain oh I don't want to go yet
but I'm coming back on
it makes it easier that I'm coming back on
okay reefling love